the British government is advising
travelers to avoid the area skies
correspondent Jason Farrell is in
Westminster for answer this evening and
Jason what is the latest advice from the
Foreign Office well the Foreign Office
yeah obviously advising people to avoid
the area but in terms of actually the
incident itself they say that they are
urgently investigating an incident in
Munich they stand ready to provide
assistance to British nationals in terms
of the Foreign Secretary we've heard
that Boris Johnson and the Defense
Secretary Michael Fallon will be in the
United States who attended a foreign
ministerial counter dayish meetings in
Washington which may or may not be
relevant to this but that's what they
are up to you know we know from the past
obviously in nice last week there was a
Cobra meeting the following day to
reevaluate security measures around
public events as this isn't a public
event more of a public place whether of
public gathering in large numbers so
perhaps there will be another one of
those but no formal confirmation of that
we have had a few political figures
tweeting so let's start with Jeremy
Corbyn he has said shocking news from
Munich my thoughts with the people of
the city at this time David Lammy has
said yet more truly horrific news my
thoughts and prayers with those in
eunuch and the emergency service teams
working to keep people safe and we've
also heard from tim feran leader of the
Liberal Democrats my thoughts and
prayers are with the people of Munich
tonight all of Britain stands with you
and of course so as we haven't heard yet
from the Prime Minister trees may was of
course as you know Sophie because you
were there in Berlin with Chancellor
Merkel this week discussing issues such
as brexit as she and her predecessor
David Cameron know often these meetings
turn to talking about events like these
and the kind of security and how people
can work together to try and stop these
things it does seem to be almost
happening
almost on a weekly occurrence at the
moment very difficult to keep up with a
number of these kind of events that are
happening but we could expect I think in
the coming hours of statement from
number 10 and again reevaluation perhaps
of security measures in the UK